you know i think i have a good
relationship with the other hosts here
at the daily wire i consider them all
friends but their one flaw is that
they're wrong sometimes whereas uh i am
always right and they are they aren't
wrong as often as the hosts on on every
other channel or site but it does happen
on occasion whereas as you know in my
case it never happens at all you mean
very compelling
and so today i'm going to take on my
daily wire colleagues engage them in
open debate
on subjects that they're wrong about and
when i say open debate i mean that i'm
going to play cherry-picked clips of
them and debate those clips instead of
them personally even though like they're
in the building it's just it's safer
this way i mean i'm not going to
actually debate ben shapiro i'm not
suicidal
so let's begin with um andrew clavin a
very wise man except when it comes to
his take on ghosts
whether or not they're ghosts is an open
question i would bet that more people
have seen a ghost than have visited
south dakota and
through history right we all believe
south dakota exists and whether we've
been there or not people tell us it
exists it's on the map we can read about
it
but we often do not believe that ghosts
exist and yet so many people have
experienced ghosts that it's kind of
like god i've i have i wrote somewhere
about god i think in my memoir the great
good thing i wrote that if we believe in
god there is more evidence than we need
but if we don't believe no evidence can
be enough and the same thing can be said
of ghosts it is oftentimes a very very
sane very down-to-earth person who says
yes i have this experience and i don't
know what to make of it but this is what
happened now i have gone searching for
ghosts my whole life and i have never
come anywhere near my daughter faith and
i when we lived in england we would look
up the most haunted hotel in a town we
would stay in the haunted hotel never
saw a damn thing i mean
one not one even
strange weirdness ever ever ever i mean
i've had strange weirdness at uh hotels
we stayed a few years ago we stayed at a
motel 6 in in
in west virginia and i we saw a ghostly
figure walking
across the parking lot it turned out
just a crackhead but uh you know so
there are strange things that happen a
couple of points here
first of all i don't actually believe in
south dakota
i've been to south dakota and i still
don't believe that it exists
as for ghosts i don't believe in ghosts
either and i'll explain why there are
two different ways i think you could
look at this
i only look at it one way but either way
i don't see how you arrive at ghosts so
so to begin with obviously if you're an
atheist right if you're a materialist
which both drew and i are not but if you
are then then there's no room for ghosts
in that view of the world we're flesh
and blood and that's it once we die our
flesh goes in the ground it decays and
and we're lost forever into nothingness
a very cheery view of life but there
could be no ghosts but then what happens
if you do believe in god okay uh what if
you have the correct worldview you're
not a materialist i think in that case
actually ghosts are even more
implausible because if by ghosts we're
talking about the souls of of dead
people still wandering the earth and
maybe we have to define what we what we
mean by ghosts i have to assume we're
not talking about say demons or other
supernatural entities that's a different
subject ghosts we must understand to be
dead human beings whose spirits are
still lingering on earth but why would
god keep disembodied dead people around
to haunt old hotels and to scare the
customers or whatever
why would god send souls back to earth
or keep them there to shut doors you
know in a creepy way to make us a spoon
fly across the room oh god
when we die this is the theological view
if we're damned if we're condemned then
we then then our destination is is we we
go to hell we we go to the destination
reserved for such souls
if we're not
then we go in the other direction
so i'm not sure i see the room
theologically for ghosts are these
condemned souls who
are being spared hell are these saved
redeemed souls who
still have to stick around on earth
scaring old ladies or is it that god
can't figure out what to do with them so
they're kind of like in a waiting room
situation it just doesn't make any sense
that's the theological problem and then
there's the empirical problem that in
the information age with cameras
everywhere nobody's produced any truly
compelling documented evidence of ghosts
i maybe call this the bigfoot conundrum
everybody's seeing them they have
beautiful hair but in in this day and
age when everyone's got cameras somehow
he never ends up on camera why are there
so many stories well because as human
beings we tend to detect agency
in things even when it isn't there
there's actually a word for this in
psychology it's called the hyperactive
agency detection device and that's when
we have this tendency as human beings
you know you're you're walking outside
at night and then a a bush is rustling
and really it's the wind that made the
bush rustle but in your mind you
immediately assume that there's a serial
killer hiding in the bushes right or a
ghost your mind tricks you into thinking
that everything that's happening there's
some sort of agency behind it and that's
where the stories come from not from
actual ghosts all right
well uh one thing i can tell you as a
four-star chef myself amateur chef but i
consider myself a four-star chef your
kitchen is not complete without great
kitchen knives and that's why you need
cami coda kamikota taps into more than
800 years of traditional techniques from
honshu japan kamikota also uses steel
sourced from mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hearty blades polishing and
sharpening them to excruciatingly fine
edge each knife is individually
inspected kamikoto is so confident that
their knives will work for you that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter that is
guaranteed kamikoto is currently having
a massive extended new year sale and on
top of that sale you can get an
additional fifty dollars off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to kamikoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra fifty
dollars today so let's move on now to
knowles this was a debate that we had a
little while ago about um about aliens
and knowles is a
a true alien skeptic and anti-alien
bigot
do the aliens exist on other planets is
there intelligent life i'll go even
further is there life at all on other
planets the one argument that drives me
the craziest is this one they say
michael
it's just it's just probable it's just
probability the universe is a gazillion
light years across it's so big so it's
just probable that there is life
somewhere else and i say you know to
ascertain a probability you need to know
literally anything about the subject
that you're talking about and when it
comes to the origins of life there's the
miller-u-ray hypothesis of the
primordial soup but the experiment
didn't work out that well because they
didn't have the right chemicals then
there was the clay hypothesis but
there's really no way to describe how it
goes from that to nucleotides right so
that kind of fell apart then there's
this idea that it came here from
martians you know from outer space which
only pushes the question off and says
well how the hell did life form there in
modernity we're told we're not we're not
special we not look there's probably a
zillion other of us and my only point is
maybe that's true but we have no
evidence we have no reason to believe
that that we're not special
my favorite part of that clip is uh ben
looking completely bored and annoyed
with the whole conversation i think it
was our best segment that we've ever
done on backstage we're talking about
aliens even though what you just heard
there was a bunch of a bunch of
propaganda michael's wrong on this the
argument he dismisses the argument that
comes from just that the vastness of the
universe is what tells us that there's
probably life on it that's not only a
good argument it's actually decisive
and the propagandists on the anti-alien
side have never come up with a good
answer to it so let's review there are
something like 100 billion galaxies in
the known universe 100
billion that's just the known universe
those that's that's what we can see from
the hubble telescope the actual number
astronomers say is probably 200 billion
or or more than that in each galaxy
there are probably a hundred billion
stars on average
100 billion each star has on average at
least one planet sometimes many more
than that so in other words the universe
is big i mean very big very very very
big to put it in in very technical
scientific terms and so i would argue
that if you're gonna look upon this vast
incomprehensible expanse
with literally countless numbers of
galaxies and planets
and assume that there's no other life
anywhere the burden of proof actually
falls on you it's impossible to prove
you're pro it's possible to prove a
negative in this case
the most logical assumption by far is
that the universe not only has other
life but is teeming with it
so michael says well there's no reason
to think that there is life you know
we've been to one planet all of us this
one
the only planet we've ever been to has
life on it we know that there are
trillions of other planets
on what basis can we possibly assume
that none of the other ones are anything
like this one if you say that then
you're the one that has to bring the
evidence i don't need to produce
evidence to support the most logical
assumption my logic is undeniable it's
like if we drove into a city with
hundreds of buildings and we drove down
one back street and didn't see anyone
and then you said well that probably
means nobody lives in the whole city and
i said well how do you know that well
look around i don't see anybody we're in
one street of a giant city
if i say no obviously there are other
people living here i am not the one
making a ludicrous or implausible claim
requiring evidential support if you
could produce evidence demonstrate
scientifically that it's just like
impossible that other life could have
developed anywhere else
absent that when you look upon this
expanse of trillions of planets
by far the most logical thing is to say
well yeah clearly there's going to be
life on those other planets some of them
at least
now we move on i think this is the most
important subject we've probably ever
debated um but it was a debate with with
very little closure no closure really
and we're gonna get that closure today
uh we move on now to ben shapiro
no as a dc guy no aquaman does not have
super strength he happens to be a strong
person but his power is to talk to fish
come on it's not like a physical
one-on-one like he's a he's a very
strong guy dude i mean jason mamoa is a
monster but that's just because he's a
monster of a human like in real life
he's a monster yeah ben and i debated
this last year
as you heard there he claims that
aquaman does not have super strength
absurd
and i can settle this right now not to
appeal to authority but i did consult
superman.fandom.com one of my favorite
websites quote aquaman possesses
superhuman strength on the order of 150
times human maximum although he's shown
feats of at least 80 tons worth of
striking lifting power but his strength
is always underrated
by people like ben shapiro considering
the company that he keeps superman
wonder woman martian manager only steel
reinforced barriers have a serious
chance of slowing him for any length of
time
so who are you gonna believe ben shapiro
or superman.fandom.com
i ask you that
[Music]
and obviously aquaman has super strength
he lives in the ocean gets into fist
fights with octopuses or whatever
aquaman you know lives in a pineapple at
the bottom of the sea
so just the water pressure alone that
deep down we're talking like 5 000
pounds per square inch that requires you
to either be a gelatinous life form like
a jellyfish is aquaman a gelatinous life
form ben
or you have to be very strong which
aquaman is super strong
i rest my kids
and i have now vanquished all of the
daily wire hosts which means i can now
steal their life force and their
salaries your soul is mine
i think that's how it works that's a
check probably with hr
we'll see